meet Peter Peter pays his taxes in the
country where he works like you and me
don't we all eat Amazon say you want to
buy a novel on the internet the web page
is accessible all over Europe but they
declare almost all their profits in
Luxembourg because they operate in
several countries with different tax
systems fiscal engineering enables
corporations to pay a fraction of the
tax as they should this means that they
do not contribute their share to society
and citizens like Peter end up paying
the difference each year 200 billion
euros of revenue is lost through tax
avoidance which could be spent on
schools health care and infrastructure
the tax contribution from working people
is much higher than it is from companies
and we need to fix this the tax rules
are outdated that come from a time where
we had factories and chimneys but
globalization and digitalization has
made location a choice for companies and
the companies choose their location to
minimize the taxes tax competition
between EU Member States often allows
corporations to pay a small amount of
tax much less than it should so who are
the bad guys the large companies
benefits they have the opportunities not
to pay taxes but think about the
American firms also Amazon Google
Facebook really good companies very good
you know paying taxes at the expense of
citizens and small businesses to make
the system simpler and more transparent
and to avoid tax competition we need to
fix this at EU level first we need to
make one tax base for all the countries
not 28 but of one definition so who
would it benefit in the end oh the
benefits - of the new system is for us
it leads to fair taxation you and I pay
taxes we want everyone to pay taxes also
the large corporate but it's also to the
benefits of the smaller firms because
they now get a level playing field into
the larger corpus
as simple guiding principle companies
should pay taxes where profits are made
we have pirates within the European
Union that enter another country and
steal from that other country is more
than piracy within the European as
Socialists and Democrats we firmly
believe that a fair and efficient tax
system is worth fighting for
a tax system for a global Europe in the
21st century not just legal but fair
[Applause]